Let's go next to our caller from the three,
three zero area code.
Who is calling today from three three zero.
Hi, Dave.
Yes, that's you.
Wow.
Hi, this is Mark from a mouth, Ohio.
Actually.
Tim Ryan's district.
Great.
What's going on?
Um, I want to ask, that's kind of a, regardless
what I'm talking, I wanted to ask about, um,
what do you see like between the news with
um, how the impeachment turned out, um, what
the DNC shenanigans in Iowa and predicted
in Nevada and with bill BARR, like basically
getting Roger Stone a free pass.
Like what do you see as like the Nat as like
the final breaking point for the most majority
of the public at this point?
That's the crazy thing.
There's not going to be one.
That's what I've been trying to tell people.
If you're waiting for the last straw of Trump's
interference and dictatorial, dictatorial,
authoritarian behavior, you're going to be
waiting forever.
You're going to be waiting through Trump's
entire second term because there is no limit
to it.
And he's gotten away with everything so far.
And I know a lot of peoples at da David Trump
saying, you've got to give Roger Stone a shorter
sentence.
This has to be it, right?
Like that.
No, it's not the, the people that are supporting
Trump do not care.
It's been a slow but slowly steady slide to
authoritarianism.
And it's just going to be a turnout thing.
If we can turn out our side, we're not going
to convince any of them to change their minds.
They're fully bought in.
It's become cult like behavior.
We've got to get out our side.
That's the only way.
And it is very dangerous to wait for the thing
that will turn the public against Trump because
it's extraordinarily unlikely to ever happen.
If we're waiting for it, we'll be waiting
for it until, uh, you know, 2025 when Trump
leaves office.
Yeah.
I don't want to think that far ahead.
Right.
Um, well the reason I brought up Tim Ryan
was because, um, this area was voted largely
for Trump, mainly because of Lawrence town.
Uh, GM plant.
Uh, Tim Ryan has been like, he's been like
the bank guy here for years.
Like the last election he was in, he blew
the competition out of the water, but pretty
much everyone that lives here said, when they
heard he was running for president, I'm like,
why would, that's the dumbest thing you get
boss.
Voters clearly seem to think the same thing.
I think he never pulled more than like zero.
Right?
Like that's my thing.
Cause like it's, there's a huge Trump base
here and I've been starting to see Bloomberg
science too.
But like, but they largely, most people largely
votes Democrat in this area.
And it's almost like, you know, people here.
Like with Trump's case in Lordstown, I heard
what they wanted to hear and it's like, you
know, it's been one broken promise after another
and it's like, I don't know.
It seems like, I don't feel like it's possible.
Ready to write everybody off.
Cause I've met, I have friends that used to
be Trump supporters or some still are.
My brother in law is, and it's like, but he's
a good guy.
I know he's not like an ignorant dumb ass,
but
Oh sure.
Yeah.
I mean listen, I'm not saying we write off
every Trump supporter.
I, I'm just, it's just not a strategy to try
to win by convincing Trump is to change their
minds.
The strategy has to be get out the vote and
mobilize different communities.
Right.
And cause I've mentioned that to him.
Like my other brother-in-law, he's not registered.
My little sister.
I'm trying to get her cause our arc deadline
is next Tuesday.
Right.
So I've been trying to convince them, but
it's like to them that's like the bottom of
their priority list.
They've got their own lives.
Yeah.
Part of it is pointing out that if people
say, well, I'm kind of busy trying to, you
know, fix things that aren't going well in
my life, a lot of those things may be fixed
through political solutions if you were more
engaged.
I think that's an important point to make.
Obviously not all.
Listen, I appreciate the phone call.
I hope to hear from you again.
Let's take a quick break and we will go right
back to the phones after this.
If you're holding, don't hang up